I have a free hand in how I run this room
I'm used to seeing my room in the top
three on the level you will want to keep
that happening I'm sensing you understand
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Star Wars and or episode 8 video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs to break down a whole
bunch of Cameo scenes to talk about multiple Cameo
scenes so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet. We'll start at the beginning and work our
way through shop by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments as we go along starting with the
episode title it was called narkina which is
a reference to narkina 5 the Imperial prison
planet that they send and or to where he's going
to have to break out of next like big prison break
that they tease in the next Big Arc so obviously
there's a bunch of episodes left there's a couple
arcs they're breaking them into the next big
adani level event on the show will probably be his
Prison Break the actual episode starts with Andor
the other recently sentenced people being taken to
the different Imperial prison planets all over
the place by Shore Troopers those are the same
types of Stormtroopers that we saw during Rogue
one for the first time and also special Cameo
scene in episode 7 that we learned about after
the fact he wasn't in the credits anywhere so
you wouldn't have known about it unless you could
pick up on his voice but this was Sam Whitmore
playing the shore Trooper who asked Andor if
he was part of the Rebellion that was going
on here and hauled him in what do you think
you're doing excuse me you keep looking around
just trying to figure out what's going on what
part of it Sam whitwer has all kinds of stealth
cameos he did it during the Mandalorian
did during the book of Boba Fett he seems
like he shows up all over the place as these
uncredited one-off characters maybe someday
we'll see a Starkiller series because they keep
showing us that Starkiller armor inside luthen's
shop he actually has two different versions of
the Starkiller armor and if you didn't watch
the Clone Wars or Star Wars Rebels and you
didn't watch the Han Solo movie he does the
voice of Darth Maul in animation but he also
did the voice during the Han Solo series like
for the live-action performance of Darth Maul if
they did a combination of Sam whitwor doing the
voice with Ray Park coming back to do the physical
appearance I can see him my mind's eye Kenobi oh
the other prison planet that they send people
to belsavis is actually from the Legends Canon
they've also used it in the newer Canon too but
a lot of time material it hasn't showed up in
the movies before it was a planet that was
previously controlled by the Rakata infinite
Empire which they referenced in an earlier episode
which is also a big Knights of the Old Republic
Easter Egg and I believe the system also housed
one of the emperor's super weapons called the
Ayah Palpatine and some of the time material but I
think that might be from the Legends Canon they're
just meant to show you that the Empire has many
many different prison planets many different types
of Prisons that they send prisoners to the one
on narkina five that they send Andor to is a Work
Camp place where they just have all the prisoners
perform duties building things for the Empire
probably weapons things that were used against the
people like the whole irony of the situation is
that the prisoners are building things that will
eventually wind up hurting their people in the
future back in the Imperial Bureau of Standards
we finally see serial car and run into deadra he
gets hauled in by her in the ISB who as of last
week's episode basically was elevated within the
ISB to get all this Authority and do whatever
she needed to do to find the rebels the funny
reason for them connecting with each other though
isn't because of all the information that he has
is actually because he's been lying and using his
authority at his new job at the Imperial Bureau
of Standards to try and find Cassie and Andor
lying about his identity to try and use this
workaround through the system to actually get to
him it's him basically doing the same thing that
he did before like just trying to use whatever
resources he has to track down Cassian Andor and
while yes he would be a great asset to Dedra the
whole joke here is that they don't want to have
anything to do with him it'll be really funny to
see the way that they pay this off like at every
single turn he represents himself as this great
asset to the Empire and it sounds like he would
potentially be a great asset to the Empire but if
the Empire doesn't want him does that mean that
he'll eventually turn and help the rebels he's
one of those characters that sounds like he's
headed for this long dark night of the Soul like
nobody wants me what am I gonna do about this the
character that has all the answers but that no one
wants to listen to he's gonna be like the most put
upon character in the Star Wars Universe during
this part of the timeline like the Meg of the Star
Wars Universe to make a Family Guy reference the
one that everybody clowns on but he does wind up
clueing deadra into the connection between Andor
Bix and luthin which you'll probably remember as
she starts torturing Bix which happens at the end
of the episode like this weirdo syril karn was
just talking about Vixen andor's connection maybe
there's actually something going on here you also
notice the interior of the interrogation room
is also really cool in a WTF way like the outer
structure here has this weird design it's meant
to Shield against all signals coming in and out
like it's meant to be like a faraday cage it's
so that the ISB can torture people however they
like and nobody will find out about it when
we travel to narkina 5 it seems like mostly
a water-based Planet because all the prison
structure seems like it's beneath the ocean
which I think is on purpose as a security measure
on top of everything to deter escapees like if you
escape you'll be underwater and it's frozen so
there's no way you're gonna make it to the top
alive basically they only have that one way out
so it'll be interesting to see how he actually
does escape it sounds like it's going to be him
running the gauntlet taking advantage of all these
different people being super lazy they make a big
deal about that later in the episode like there
are all these deficiencies in the security amongst
all the guards like oh sorry they're short one man
down on another level so I had to help out there
and that's why I'm late here that's why he was
clocking all of the guards different activities
because they'll probably use that when he tries
to escape it's meant to be another reference that
Andor made earlier this season to luthen talking
about how The Empire had grown so overconfident
they're so fat and lazy anybody can just walk in
and take whatever they want they're gonna pay that
off when he tries to escape during the ISB meeting
too when Dedra is explaining what's going on next
I love the way that Colonel yularen seems like he
could barely be bothered to actually listen to
her like go on go on I'm reading my report here
it's like being in a big meeting giving a huge
presentation but the person you're giving it to
is just reading their phone the whole time this is
just meant to set up them taking a larger Force to
pharynx their whole goal though is to track down
and or use him to find luthen who they're calling
axis because they call him the axis of a bunch
of different Rebel cell activities across the
Galaxy and after re-watching the episodes a couple
times I definitely do think that Dedra is probably
going to wind that being andor's long-lost Sister
and she's just been reconditioned just kind of
changed her appearance a little bit so that she
doesn't seem like andor's sister like you look
at his sister in the past she looks like this but
you look at Dedra in present day obviously she's
meant to look different but if you notice Dedra
actually changed her appearance here like she
dyes her hair blonde because her roots are all
brunette her eyebrows are brunette her accent
might sound a little bit different but I think
that she's just putting the accent on like the
accent is fake she wasn't born with that accent
I think ultimately what we'll find out is that
she was captured by The Imperials and she was
conditioned by them when she was growing up and
that's why she's acting the way she is now like
she isn't pretending she actually is genuinely an
imperial trying to rise through the ranks clearly
those two characters her and Andor are the main
characters of the series like way more than luthen
and Andor are so the whole show seems like it's
turning mostly on what Andor and Deborah do and
I think if she does wind up being his long-lost
sister we need to ask because she's seen his
face like they show his face in the middle of
their briefing here does she actually recognize
him from the past or has something caused her to
to forget about him either way I think they're
playing the show on this Empire Strikes Back
Return of the Jedi Luke Skywalker Darth Vader
reveal kind of moment where an Empire Strikes
Back Luke Skywalker learns that his father is
Darth Vader for the first time I think during
season one early Theory Andor will find out that
his sister is deadra and it'll be like a big WTF
kind of reveal so that going into season two is
kind of like a Return of the Jedi kind of twist
where Luke Skywalker tried to bring Darth Vader
back to the light side in Andorra will try to win
his sister maybe deadra could be somebody else
but maybe Dedra win her back to the Rebellion
you can let me know in the comments whether you
think deadra is andor's long-lost sister or not
but I think that's the whole Twist of the show is
that we'll find out who she really is at the end
of season one and then season two will be trying
to win her back we get a bit of a tutorial andor's
new narquina 5 Prison and obviously our big Cameo
scene with Andy Circus not playing a creature or
anything like that that's the other big surprise
like one is Andy Circus but also it's Andy Circus
playing a normal person if you don't remember
the other big deep cut here is that he played
snoke during the sequel Trilogy you can make all
the funny snoke theories that you want obviously
he's just meant to be a completely new character
on the series they have this weird thing with
7-2 like there are seven different levels in the
prison several different rooms per level and seven
different people per table with seven tables in
each of the rooms the Empire definitely likes the
number seven his name on the show is Kino Loy and
the way they're playing in them is just like this
dick that's managing the room because his sentence
is almost over so he's risen through the ranks of
different prisoners but the basic idea is that
you step out of line You'll basically die like
they have the joke about people sleepwalking which
they pay off later in the episode like either the
guy slept walk or he killed himself by walking off
of his bunk in the middle of the night I actually
think the latter is true I think that he did it
on purpose like I said they organized the show
with a couple different story arcs across a couple
different episodes in the current story arc is now
and or in prison and breaking out of prison
so this will probably only last for a couple
episodes so the big prison break that they tease
that he'll eventually have to pull will probably
happen either in the next couple episodes they
could drag it to the end of the season but I don't
know if they'll wait that long I believe the next
big event will happen in episode 11 and 12 like
the prison break will happen in episode 10 then
11 and 12 be like the last Big Arc of the season
during mon mothma's new party she tries to whine
and dine a bunch of other Senators winning then
to her cause to try and work back on Emperor
Palpatine's latest security measure that he
enacted with the legislation they also referenced
that when Andor is talking to the prisoners like
did something happen recently because everybody's
sentences got doubled like the Empire has gone
hardcore now it's because of The Big Heist on
aldani so the irony of the situation is that
Andor caused the reason that he got thrown into
prison indirectly like if he hadn't pulled off the
heist they would have the extra security measures
he wouldn't have gotten thrown into prison for
six years all the other prisoners wouldn't have
had their sentences doubled so if they found out
that Andor was responsible for all that they'd
probably be really pissed off at him during the
dinner too man mothma's husband seems like he goes
even further towards Pro Empire stance because he
keeps referencing the old ways versus the new ways
mon mothma keeps hinting that she doesn't want to
have anything to do with that like they talk about
the old ways of Chandra how Sheen or husband got
married when they were 15 years old which seems
crazy but apparently that's a custom on chandrala
you kind of get this Vibe too that her husband
might think that she's having an affair with take
homea because she spent so much time talking or
thinking about him like where did take home ago oh
he's over here okay I'm gonna go talk to him now
her daughter also seems like she's picking up on
some of that Vibe too but she doesn't know exactly
what mon mothma is up to that has something to do
with the Rebellion remember they're trying to use
his Banks to move Rebel money and even though he
says there's some issues lately I think that'll
just continue they'll figure out whatever those
problems are my early Theory right now is that
her daughter who seemed like she kind of hated
her before because she seemed like she loved the
Empire will learn what she's really doing and
eventually her relationship with her daughter will
get much better but something really tragic will
happen like either her daughter and her husband
will die or just her daughter will die and that
will push her fully into the Rebellion life she'll
become much more active in the Rebellion than she
already is also you may have noticed one of the
Senators that mon mothma talks to here is named
yvin, y v i n. And even though that's a brand new
name brand new person in the Star Wars Universe I
think the name is meant to be a direct reference
to Yavin for their future rebel base in Rogue
One In A New Hope like every meeting that she has
during this dinner here is meant to reference the
Rebellion what happens during the future movies
we also get a little bit more of monmouth's
backstory we found out she became a senator at
age 16. that's also the same age that Princess
Leia was when she became a senator but Princess
Leia is supposed to be the youngest senator in
the history of the Empire because they were both
16 when they became Senators Princess Leia was
probably just a few months younger than mon mothma
was when she became one still wondering if we're
ever going to see Princess Leia Cameo during the
series like a teenage version of Leia because I
think the events of the series are meant to stop
right before the events of Rogue one and that's
around the time where Princess Leia had become a
senator we're starting to get a bunch more cameos
on the series so they might save some of that for
season two when we go back to ferrix we find out
that things have gotten even worse because the
Empire have tightened the screw even more Dedra
is now hauling in different people interrogating
them trying to find Andor his mother is getting
more ill hurting herself trying trying to help the
rebels as she thinks that she's helping them Bix
finds out that she hurt herself trying to open
an old tunnel allowing Rebels to get in and get
rid of the Empire they'll probably pay that off
towards the end of the season when Andor tries
to return to pharynx we also find out that on the
rebel side of things valsartha and Sinta have come
to ferrix also looking for Andor remember kleya
implied that she wanted her to kill Andor but it
seems like they're trying to position valsartha
as a much better character like she wants to have
this relationship with cinta she also probably
doesn't want to kill Andor when she winds up
leaving at the end of the episode I think the
idea is that she'll eventually try to help and
or Escape like they'll both continue through the
Rebellion don't know if they'll kill her off by
the end of the season hopefully they'll keep her
to season two because they're just introducing a
couple really interesting characters we also
get a little bit more of her backstory too
she's from a rich family and turned against their
ways on Coruscant the same way that man mothma is
basically doing except she's still a senator but
she's using her family money to fund the rebellion
and obviously slowly doing more and more to help
them back inside luthen's shop they've moved the
Jedi 10 simple Guardian armor to the middle
display that's what this helmet is here you
probably recognize that I'm not sure where this
helmet to the right comes from but it does look
familiar if you think you know where it's from
write in the comments below and the helmet on
the left I believe is the one from the prequels
part of the headdress that Padme wears in The
Phantom Menace the Mandalorian armor looks similar
to jango fett's armor and the mandalorian's beskar
armor later in the timeline I don't know if this
is meant to be beskar but it probably is just
because the whole thing inside luthen's shop is
that he deals in super rare expensive artifacts
and even though they cycle the placement of
artifacts in the middle the Starkiller armor
is still sitting in the background there just
because it looks so cool like that doesn't move
around they also have a second set of Starkiller
armor in the back of the shop too then luthin goes
to see saw gerrera who they bring back in the
next Cameo of the episode obviously earlier in
the timeline so he's still alive now when he says
the long way around that's also a bit of a Matt
Smith Doctor Who reference Matt Smith obviously
playing a version of Daemon Targaryen on House
of the Dragon which I just did a whole bunch of
videos for love the scene with saw gerrera and
luthen just going back and forth because no one
wants to admit actually pulling off the heist like
okay well if you did do it we'll say that it was a
great job like I think saw gerrera kind of figured
out like oh yeah it was definitely you that pulled
it off even though you don't want to admit it if
you didn't watch any of the bad batch episodes
they actually brought the character on earlier
in his timeline he's basically a character who
didn't want to have anything to do with either
the republic or with the separatists during the
Clone Wars on his home planet of onderon he fought
to try and keep them independent that's why one of
their big arguments is saw gerrera not wanting to
become part of the larger rebellion and work with
other rebel cells like I don't want to work with
that guy was because the other guy luthen wants
him to work with Anton Krieger was a separatist
where Saw Gerrera was a neo-republican like in
neo-republic so they're on opposite sides of
the Clone War and now because of what's happened
with the Empire they both find themselves on the
same side and that's kind of the general idea
across the entire Rebellion you had the Clone
Wars with the separatists versus The Republic
but now with the rise of the empire you have
the Rebellion versus the Empire and a lot of
former separatists working with lot of Former
Republic when he references the Gorman front
that's a reference to a recent atrocity that
the Empire committed killing a bunch of innocent
people the partisan Alliance is just the Former
Republic people working with the separatists
inside the rebellion and they end the episode
with his big WTF moment of deadra getting her
hands on Bix getting ready to interrogate her
like I said Dedra is trying to find out where
Andor is so that she can get to luthen and crush
whatever this Rebellion is that she thinks that is
developing because we keep coming back to ferrix I
think the whole idea is that Andor will escape
and eventually come back to ferrix so whatever
big final Conflict they have during season one
it will happen on pharynx Injustice Andor is
returning Dedra will also probably learn about
andor's identity and they'll come face to face
and that's when I think that they'll figure out
that they're the long-lost siblings but if he's
spotted any of their Easter eggs or references
in the episode that I didn't mention in the
video just write down below in the comments and
they just dropped all the Star Wars tales of the
Jedi episodes I'll do a full breakdown video for
that tomorrow just because there's so much stuff
that they revealed there's a bunch of new Ahsoka
stuff they have this whole new back backstory on
Count Dooku like you could call tales of the Jedi
Dooku's story because most of it is about him we
get more Qui-Gon Jinn and they brought back yaddle
like they actually explain what happened to yaddle
during the prequels why she just disappeared
wait wait for that everyone click here for my
new house the Dragon season 2 video and click
here for my house the Dragon episode 10 finale
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!